oh boy oh boy
today is exciting so we are super into
those little tiny mini foods wipe out
these a while ago on Amazon and these
food Lee this is not English thanks so
good it's fine let's go through these
and see which ones we want to make we've
got little teeny tiny sushi like look at
this little sweet actual sushi no it's
an actual sushi it's like candy gummy
sushi okay just check Donuts
oh I really want to do this one but look
at this little tiny ice cream cone okay
cancel everything put the ice cream come
on look at this this little teeny tiny
ice cream cones I think we should do
this one I don't even know it's like a
little bento box we've got a lot of
options so let us know what you guys
would like us to do next
because I don't know if this is gonna
take a long time like what do we do Matt
these instructions I can't endure this
is not my language so I'm not sure but
let's through this one okay let's start
with the ice cream and see what happens
there's pictures we just gotta figure it
out I guess it doesn't look like there's
much in here ready for this oh yeah
let's open it up okay this is not gonna
go well figure out how to open box
oh very lovely scissors
we understand that picture that's it
right here cut oh this is super cute
look oh oh gotta cut this out why I
think that's supposed to be like a
little plate
we can do without the plate it shows
these little things you're supposed to
cut out you can't eat it so like what we
actually do with it both edibles on
things we could eat I like the boina
safe okay what's it say my box it's not
my language oh I mean one of the first
picture look like you get the cone out
okay we got the cone cone in the little
wafer I feel like a giant old
look but it's it's telling us to put
water in here let's use a translator oh
wait wait wait what we cut off this
corner oh we don't need a translator
we'll figure this out with our brain yes
I'm still gonna download the translate
because I thought I can oh look at this
look at this stuff isn't it nice make
two of these
Oh cuz it's translating to Spanish it's
doing instant translation hell picture
hold on don't move
yeah this isn't going well okay she's
our brain honestly this is what we do
fill that up with water
oh that's what they mean you got
Malloy's baby but not P so put that in
you sure yeah you sure no put it in here
yep don't yell at me
not can I get another watch into the
water Hey so no we mix this up real good
excuse to get in okay nice loving goo it
smells nice does it not get colder it's
like fake ice cream mix with this this
is all mixed up real nice Oh what to do
dad you turn around a minute Anna wait
was just to break up the wafers a little
yeah that's like a step last can you
hold that yes if we can get the whole
scoop in what I put it on the other side
pays nice case very nice
really let's just stick that in there
okay yeah place it up
Oh God they flip boo it's a little gooey
to be fair I'm gonna die potentially oh
no I'm gonna die I've been in a box for
probably years really really just eating
chemicals I don't think that's the
problem is this all we have to do is
this the entire thing yes it's boring no
I'm having a swell time except I'm
probably gonna drop at the end of this
video now would you like you have a mini
plate I do I know but I don't know him I
don't know where it is either
there's a mini plate somewhere we just
want to couple okay so now we've got our
little teeny tiny plates and everything
looks great so we're gonna do you want
to break those down
oh I'll fill up one of our combs well
where's the pink the pink is not coming
out yet it looks so silly
you're gonna open up our I had made a
teeny tiny message teeny tiny bit I
can't believe this is an entire video
you've done work that's true what I did
the teeny tiny sprinkles will you put
them all over there so yeah this is
wrinkled bum
oh yes oh you wait what's great
sprinkles art staying on the go it's
super sticky it's so small that's cool
okay we can satin or look okay super
stack we have to taste it after I've
just did Oh why'd I do that I thought it
was a conceptual icing like it just
really is a very beautiful work of art
it tastes like if you've accidentally
thing licked a hot tire that's off how
would you even I don't know I just
imagine like rubber like I take some
melted rubber it's super cute it's so
cute look it up oh wow me the same nails
you do dips this cancer is
there okay we try it I don't know let's
just take a little bite
okay
Oh gah big mouthful of dough huh it's
not good at all
okay so I don't I do not like it it's a
drink help me that's it
I'm not even gonna try this because this
was so gross but I will say wait is this
is this edible what wait a minute it's
not edible I have no idea
poppin cookin it just opens it says okay
but those Orbeez also said something and
I can't read this so I actually have no
idea I would assume this is edible did I
just eat and go I did what yeah hop and
cook and edible oh my god what did you
do to me yes okay it is DIY candy kids
our edible have I made of edible candy
powder okay perfect it was actually
slightly concerned because I was looking
at this and I thought this doesn't look
like something I mean it does look
edible but it did not I did no I don't
think that tasted well thanks for
watching thanks to Jennifer hanging out
in my kitchen making a little teeny tiny
ice cream come let us know if you would
like us to make any more of these
because I've got a lot of them I vote
for doughnuts please we can make a
Thanksgiving meal of tiny meals I'm into
it okay I'm done
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
soon I got a two year all wish to do
with us I'm gonna put it back in its box
let's deposit this into the trash your
obedient little disgust
[Music]